as podcast has bad words hey hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome the episode 171 today
we're going to talk about independence
we're gonna talk about rejection we're
gonna talk about creating meaningful
work without gatekeepers and and who
better to do that within a comedian so
we have a special guest in the studio
today and your shows is with us thanks
what's been here thanks for course so
Andrew if you're not familiar with the
format of the show basically we don't do
interviews we don't usually have guests
on what we do is we help people answer
their questions when we do bring someone
on it's to instead of just interrogate
you let's let's look at your worldview
with respect to some people's questions
cool so we've got some questions today
about independence about rejection about
creating meaningful work without
gatekeepers and that first question
today is a voicemail from Vita in Norway
how should I prioritize between my
creativity and my university degree to
give a little background I'm a very
creative person who loves taking
pictures writing drawing huh muttering
knitting and so on I feel like this is
truly my passion but something my father
said to me once has stuck with me he
said don't make a living out of your
hobby that takes the fun out of it and
this has kept me from trying to make a
living out of my creative side which is
one of the reasons why I'm currently
taking a degree in national economics to
make a living out of that what I like my
subjects I've been inspired by listening
to you guys talking about adding value
to people's lives and I am sort of
second-guessing my choice because that's
what I feel like I'm doing when I'm
creating art however the money aspects
of actually making a living of my art
also terrifies me do you have any tips
yeah I think it's really sad that we
have to talk about this where it's how
do i prioritize my my creativity and my
university degree yeah it's like [ __ ] we
do so much we've been sold this meme of
the American Dream I know or actually
and she's in Norway so the American
Dream has permeated their borders you
over there recently Andrew and and and
the thing is we're given this
prescription of how to I don't know
live a supposedly successful life and if
we do anything outside of that then man
its what we're doing something we're not
supposed to do yeah you know I think
like her dad's advice on like you know
don't don't make money off of your hobby
like that's a way to kill it I think
he's like halfway right and what what I
mean by that is is like if you force
yourself to make money from your hobby
you can absolutely kill it cuz I'm I
mean I'm assuming when you were like I'm
gonna be a comedian you weren't like you
know what I'm gonna get rich off of
telling jokes yeah yeah it's it's uh you
wait you're saying like I didn't think
that is that is that what you thought I
mean how do I never cared about money
yeah you know and that's what came I
guess what came first the money or the
jokes oh definitely the jokes still
waiting on the money no the what I think
that her father is right in a way I
think what happens is when you start
doing your your hobby as a job you find
out what it is you really liked about
your hobby mm-hmm and what a lot of
people don't like is business right and
business is business regardless of what
it is it doesn't matter if you're
selling you know her pictures or if
you're you know selling a podcast
whatever there's a business component to
anything you do so you might just not
like that maybe her father just doesn't
like that you know so you you taking the
picker like me I love creating comedy
that's my favorite part creating it
going onstage making shows for myself
and other people the icing on the cake
is when the people see it okay so like
it starts from like oh what a cool idea
okay I'm gonna give it to some people
and if they laugh that's even that's
icing and then money sprinkles right
yeah so it's like I'm starting at what I
love about it and and operating as at
that as my blue that is my baseball
you know if you're operating within like
the success equals money matrix you're
only gonna be happy when you hit the
money amount right right probably not
going to be happy then either because
because I know be enough yeah the
money's not gonna fulfill you alone it's
like being a billionaire so stupid
because like the second you become a
billionaire you're the poorest
billionaire Yeah right it's like you
think you but people get out dumb they
are like Jay Z's like I want to be the
first you know billionaire the first
hip-hop billionaire or something like
that's like you're ready to be miserable
are you ready to be the brokest
[ __ ] at the billionaire meter
your whole life trying to be rich and
then once you're a billionaire you don't
hang out with these millionaires these
poor [ __ ] so now you're
isolated you're on this island where
you're the brokest billionaire you know
bragging about your rented jet or
whatever the [ __ ] you do with amongst
these real wealthy people and you can't
relate to these other other folks it's
just the worst matrix is defining it by
my money and what do you say that to
about the isolation of it I have a
friend who's a pastor and and you know
he has a decent amount of wealthy
congregants I don't even know what yeah
people who show up to church and and he
said he realizes like quite often
they're the ones who will require more
attention not because they have worse
problems but the the problem of
isolation is one that you it's really
hard to solve with money because yeah
you can surround yourself with people
but you're not surrounding yourself with
the relationship yes that's true there's
two things with that it's like those
people have no hope that's the thing
like rich people have no hope poor
people have the hope that when though
but when they become rich they'll be
happy mm-hmm because that's their carrot
right yeah so it's like every every rich
person you talk to everyone will say
money does not make you happy right
every poor person you talk to will tell
you once I'm rich I'm gonna be happy
that's right right so and it's not
either of their fault it's like you
don't know you don't need something
until you have it mm-hmm
right yeah like you don't know that you
didn't need a chair for this podcast
right right
so it's like you and that's the
perspective with money it's like I
learned once I made money that my
lifestyle didn't change from making you
know quarter-million dollars a year to a
half million dollars yet like nothing
changed yeah my happiness and she ain't
nothing changed I mean money just solves
money problems money and those are real
problems yeah I'm not mitigating what
that is I'm saying after a certain
amount it makes no difference at least
for me you know so like you have this
situation with these rich people they
don't have hope they don't have the
carrot they have everything that they
thought would make them happy and
they're not yeah that's why these rock
stars kill themselves yeah why would you
not your whole life you thought this is
what's gonna make me happy and then it
didn't well it's a David Foster Wallace
said he in one of his books he wrote
that most suicides are dead long before
they pulled the trigger and the thing
you talk about Ryan and like in your TED
talk for example when you you said I was
living paycheck to paycheck but I wasn't
really living at all like I was alive
but I wasn't living to a certain extent
because you were focused on that one
very narrow metric it's one resources
and and we don't have it it feels much
more important than it is the same is
true with virtually any resource that we
don't have though if we don't don't have
our health all of a sudden everything
crashed down and that is a real resource
that you can't just get back it's not a
you can't use other resources to get
your health back necessarily I think the
first like instance of that for me was a
like in the fifth grade when I finally
got a pair of like Nike airs and it was
like you know the cheap version of Nike
Air I mean it wasn't off-brand but it
wasn't no Air Jordans you know and it's
like I've had him and I was happy for
about five minutes
yeah and it's gone because you didn't
it's like your kid with the magic trick
mm-hmm you didn't want them you wanted
to want them yeah you see the difference
it's the carrot yeah
what we the reason heaven happens when
you die it's the carrot
need to care it yeah but most people
need the carrot like I think there's
different stages
good question Vita I think there's
different stages in life you know where
you operate and we've all gone through
these different stages and you know
maybe one my buddy roll calls it the you
know the vegetable stages you're going
to work you're come back home you're
going to work and come back home and
there's nothing wrong with that
none of these are better than the other
they're just different stages and next
you go into like the Y stage right you
know which is like you start
contemplating things like why why does
this cup have to look like this you know
why why do I have to eat breakfast in
the morning why like you start just
asking why about weird things in your
life right and then the next stage is
where [ __ ] gets tricky this is where
comedy operates but a lot of creativity
operates is things both are and aren't
mmm not is or isn't is and isn't right
okay yeah that's a very like for me
that's comedy and that is your attention
to its all the tensions right because we
want the world to be defined in ways
that we can digest it either or no yes
my aunt isn't ones and zeroes whereas no
it's 1n0
that's it the maggot hat is a horrible
hat is it yeah so is the viking hat
people wear that is and isn't i first i
first her ride on to your work you you
did a stand-up special called 441 and
then became an album 5 5 1 we'll put a
link to that in the show notes and and
the thing that you do in there is you
create tension in comedy i think is one
of the of two creative places that we
can we can deal with life's most most
difficult issues kafka said jokes are
what we use to talk about life's most
difficult issues and he what he meant
there was like you you can only when
something is so difficult so complex so
fraught with with all this political
tension you see it in the news there are
two places that can they can deal with
the jokes and you did an amazing job
five one with that Ryan and I were we
were in Chicago we went we had a
speaking gig out there and we're in the
airport I'm like hey man you got to
listen to this and like we were we were
sharing your phones like a weight one
coca-cola with two straws is great and
we're listen to it and we were just
cracking up and need like O'Hare Airport
man and like people are looking us like
we're just total idiots but what you
were doing in there is you're talking
about fraught topics and and and
distilling it down the only way that it
makes it palatable is through humor
through jokes through really good jokes
and and I think fiction can do that as
well I think absolutely some point yeah
yeah Zadie Smith has been she had a
short story in The New Yorker recently
where she was talked about the me to
movement and it's something that if you
won't have a debate about that it just
kind of much yeah you're throwing yeah
you you're just you're throwing feces
feces at each other whereas if you write
about in fiction it adds that that
element of separation it's like a
cartoon yeah and get everything you can
get away with anything in a cartoon you
kill Kenny every episode of this kids
show yeah right right like like frozen
that girl is a [ __ ] Elsa is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] kill everybody and it's like a fun
kids movie cartoon you can actually say
real [ __ ] because we're - you know what
it is it's easier to show than tell
telling is useless right so it's like
the cartoon we can show yeah and there's
that little filter of separation like
this isn't real
and that's what happens with jokes a lot
- it's like if you operate in the silly
part of a serious situation it's like
okay I can I can enjoy that I can take
that in approach it like it is real then
you're going to fail I mean it's the
worst when you have someone ask you you
to explain your joke to them explain me
the magic trick yeah I won't do it I
won't explain the joke I like explain
how we got here or like what I'll
explain what I wanted to do with the
joke but I'll never explained like this
is what you do you you actually do this
thing on on YouTube your YouTube channel
which is youtube.com slash the enter
show so I believe I will put a link to
that in the show notes as well so you
you have
decided to sort of branch out and do
your own thing and you're creating these
own shows and what I like about this is
they don't have to conform to a
particular structure we're like what we
need twenty two minutes with
seven-minute commercial breaks and and
no you-you-you find what works for the
actual material itself and you do this
one show called inside jokes and what
you're doing there is you take some
comedian friends you sit down the
restaurant together and you're not
explaining the jokes but you're taking
the most offensive jokes jokes you can't
even get to work in front of crowds yet
let's let's dissect these together let's
find the funny in this because I know
there's something here and if I'm
relating this back to Vitas question
there's probably something here and and
what I mean by that is okay you have
this creative side but you're also going
to school for what she said was a degree
in national economics yeah Matt now my
question for you is how can you apply
creativity to that degree you you've
done this Andrew you start out as comedy
degree in that in Norway it's like have
oil be Saudi Arabia with snow - no the
national economic situation in Norway
stick a spike in the ground when that
really really important black liquid
seeps up bottle it and sell it to people
you're not doing anything brilliant over
there Norway comedy you you that was
your thing but then you also found a way
to combine that with with other things
with just talking on the radio we're
talking on a podcast I first discovered
you because of brilliant idiots right
I showed up because of Charlemagne but
I've stayed because of you and I'll tell
you I mean you actually got me to listen
to a damn sports podcast right with with
your podcast flagrant - so so although
it's I mean it's it's sort of a thinly
veiled sports coat pocket it's not the
comedy podcasts were you occasionally
toward the end talk about sports oh we
do that as a Vale for like the PC
culture all right because I was like
nobody that's like a like
angry on Twitter or social justice
warrior like sports like though that
Venn diagram doesn't exist cancel this
guy doesn't also like the Eagles right
like if I call it that I keep all those
people away and then we can really talk
about what we want to talk about we can
be flagrant we can be you know offensive
we can make the jokes that everybody
makes in private in a public space and
that's really what everybody has
gravitated towards it's like this like
two hours of normalcy in their week
they're like [ __ ] I like I'm hearing the
same jokes I make with my friends other
people making I don't feel so lonely
there's community aspect to it yeah but
you do so in a way where you capture the
sentiment of what's what's going on in
sort of people's heads I think yeah yeah
and then yeah you can talk about sports
occasionally yeah the one problem with
the sports thing is it does deter the
majority of women from showing up and
it's like these women just aren't really
into that sports I mean we do have our
Lady [ __ ] are witty [ __ ] army
right because the show is analysis by
[ __ ] right so and they do show up
but it is also a filter for them and you
know there's certain places that have
done a great job of like engaging women
even in sports content like barstool did
a great job you know so I got to think
of my next the next thing I got to do is
like bring women into the flagrancy
because when they're at the shows they
love it no they listen to brilliant
idiots they love it they're there for it
it's just finding a way to tap into them
and and help them get on board and
that's the next the next project I'll
probably do will be about like like
decoding the fuck-boy yeah I think
that's what it like is every couple
years women need a manual for men just
it says the same thing right it's like
every two years it's like he's not that
into you every two years there's a new
book that says the exact same thing but
I'll do that in a way that's like hey
I'm gonna help you you know not lie to
yourself about the dates you're going on
yeah I love the recipe that we kind of
like I feel like we kind of uncover it
here a little bit so regardless of what
Vida does
if she's putting money first with her
economic economics degree or with her
art like that's a problem it doesn't
matter what she what she inserts there
if money is first that's going to be an
issue especially when it's first by a
long shot
yes so the the recipe that I'm seeing
here is you have nothing to lose
yeah Vita you're in Norway physically
can't be homeless exactly can't be broke
you can just you can say I'm not gonna
work anymore and the government will
give you food and give you shelter yeah
if there's anybody who should just
[ __ ] go for it everyone Norway should
be an artist why you guys do anything
else is besides me no I would be a
[ __ ] painter if I live in Norway yeah
get an oil or get into art over there
stay home if not go do your art and then
truly find out what you like about the
art you like the creative process do you
like selling it you might like selling
it you might like the hustle you that
might be something that interest you
find your interest but if you have
something that you enjoy doing and you
have the opportunity to do it during the
day [ __ ] do it yeah so easy so here's
a recipe I think we got for Vita is
first put first your what you like put
put first your passion like cultivating
that passion I don't want to say live
your passion that is like some overrated
ass of advice that job talk about but
but I think that you should cultivate
your passion that's number one number
two is solve a problem so when people
are laughing like you're making them
laugh that's that's you know that is
that is solving a problem for those
people they want to laugh at you give
them jokes and then three is the money
so so if you go at it in that order
you're gonna feel way more complete Vita
if you just put money first like yeah
that's that's a problem your dad's right
if you want to kill your hobby just
start thinking about how you're gonna
make money off of art that's a great boy
and that's yeah that's how you kill your
hobby yeah we did we did a whole podcast
episode with a musician who moved to
Nashville to pursue his dream and when
he got down there he was basically stuck
writing corporate jingles this was Paul
from Kenya City and he's like it totally
destroyed his love for music and he in
fact had to walk away from he went to go
work at Home Depot just so he could walk
away for a while walk back to
actual music where the money wasn't
first he wasn't doing it just for the
record contract or the the paycheck from
the the radio station and it changed
everything for him and eventually as you
started solving those problems as you
start making people laugh the money
starts to show up dude you know lucky
you are Vita that you have something you
like to do like so so few people have
things they like to do yeah like that's
why TV exists because people don't have
things they like to do right they're
like all right [ __ ] it I'll just sit
here and I'll watch the show cuz that'll
distract me from doing nothing which is
what I was gonna do before you have an
activity you like to do you can do it in
the day you can do it at night you can
do it literally 24 hours if you want you
can travel around the world taking
pictures it's like what a [ __ ] gift
that you have something you enjoy right
that's crazy yeah I can't tell you how
many people like though they'll send in
a question how do I uncover my passion
how do I find how do I figure out which
hobbies I like best I totally agree Vita
knows what she likes best boom she's got
it over York the battle is done or
whatever yeah what that that term is but
your fine time you got you know what
time it is it is time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media
indeed so Andrew the minimalists were on
Twitter at the minimalists and what
Facebook and Instagram you're at Andrew
Schultz on all the relevant platforms
yes they can find you there and usually
we do during this lightning round as we
answer questions with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response but don't worry we really just
ramble on a little bit and hopefully
find something to tie it up with tied up
with a bow yeah you can't tie something
up with a bow podcast Shawn I'll tweeze
it out for you yeah good man yeah so
what's our first question right our
first question is from bilder I've
created a new product slash invention
congratulations that's awesome builder
if you were me how would you go about
creating demand for it man here's here's
the problem like if i short answer is a
card has never pulled a horse
and if you're if you're walking around
the solution looking for a problem
that's how you create the pharmaceutical
industries like clinical trial is great
drug I need to make some aid so can cure
it so so yeah I mean I don't I think I
think the opposite is true you go out
and you saw it you solve problems as
Ryan was saying earlier you look for a
problem to solve you you look my guess
is in comedy or in podcasting and your
what what do you do with respect to like
creating a demand for the podcast I
don't think that even comes up and
you're right your thought processes
isn't like I'm gonna create a demand
with this podcast no no demands have to
exist that white space has to be there I
get the white space is what we refer to
like a space in the market where nobody
has tapped into it just yet and that
Scotty exists organically and you have
to hope the thing that you love to do
lines up with it it just so happened
like I've been doing the same comedy for
years Society shifted right so then it
turned me from a guy who was you know
edgy doing this kind of comedy back in
the day to a guy now who's brave I never
looked at myself as brave but people are
like oh you do these jokes in this
climate what that's crazy so I was like
oh we need to create a space for this
how do I create a space for this I need
to insulate myself make it so that
nobody can take anything away from me am
i dependent on network am i dependent on
these different things I was okay create
independence podcast patreon etc okay
I've got a little bubble I've got the
crew got everything now I can really put
out the content and what are they gonna
do cancel me they can't have anything to
cancel right so it's like if you have a
solution I guess she said I don't know
what she said she said so Bella says I
created a new product slash invention
how do I go about creating so she's got
a solution if you have a solution then
there should be a problem that the
demand is already there if you have a
solution there's a demand all you need
to do is give it to somebody yeah give
it to someone who's the problem what's
the product does she say no she's
worried we'll take it we do we we take
your invention and producing a mass on a
mass scale as the minimalist
well you know what it's like when I
think about when when Josh and I first
started this like we we hated our jobs
we're like get us out of here yeah so we
came across minimalism and then helped
us to kind of reprioritize where we were
focusing all our resources not just
money but time energy attention all of
that we didn't go from okay yeah
minimalism all right dude now look what
are the top 20 things we can do to make
money right and what it wasn't it wasn't
product first and then create Sam and it
was oh okay what we're gonna do a blog
people keep asking for a book well [ __ ]
we are the minimalist maybe we should
write a book on minimalism
okay so then we wrote a book on
minimalism and so forth it's on that's
how we've done this whole thing it's
never been again cart before the horse
you know cliches are cliches for a
reason here's my pet the answer is
creations that add value will forge
their own demands so it doesn't matter
to you know to andrew's point it's like
when you are doing something you love do
it because you love it and hope to god i
hope to god there's a demand for but
here's the thing there's over 7 billion
people in the world the good news is is
like some of them are probably on the
same page as you selling books of any
year so you go back to last year the
absolute best sellers the books that
sold the most units out of all of them
the the brakeaway oh my god I'll never
be able to sell them any books reach
less than 2% of the population yeah oh
and by the way it was years after we
published that book well now how about
our book oh oh I mean our books never
sell the the the as much as maybe like
you know these 7 million no I'm saying
the best of the bestsellers nearly yeah
yeah yeah we we're somewhere in the
middle of the bestseller list the best
of the bestsellers yeah they only
touched 2% people yeah and that's
actually good news because that means
there's a market and you don't even have
to touch 2% you can find someone that
your product is for yeah what's the next
question right our next question is from
Austin how do you minimally weight sorry
Austin how do you get minimally rejected
[Laughter]
they asked for yeah just sit around
watch TV and do what you base on what
you asked for
yeah you know I mean it's like you're
asking a man could have a little more
room on my seat like that's not a big
thing so even if you see if the guy says
no it's like it's not a big deal if he
says no but we flinch as if it is I
think that the flinch is even bigger
don't you think if you said hey man can
I have the aisle seat oh yeah it is but
so there there are our degrees of
flinching yeah sure but I think we
flinch like I don't want this person to
dislike me yeah and you have mastered
that because you have to get on stage
every night yeah and you seek rejection
in a way because you know occasionally
you're working on new material something
that is for sure going to bomb yeah are
you gonna say it the wrong way
or maybe you just you come up after
someone the energy is different and
you're working hard to make it your own
sure there's gonna be some rejection
there and I think if we avoid rejection
we avoid something more meaningful yeah
and you have to in a way seek it out
yeah and and man that's really difficult
because because of that flinch right
yeah it absolutely is I mean rejection
is a very interesting thing I wish I
could sit here and say I've conquered it
I haven't conquered it there's times
where I feel you know some people might
look at me like wow you you you really
you know surpassed rejection you're
you're invincible because you don't care
about being rejected there's times where
like I'm in an elevator I want to ask
somebody something I'm like let me not
bother them probably on some level
because I'm like what if they have an
attitude then I gotta address this as I
will say this though but you have it
that's funny the elevator thing you're
having an imaginary fight with like a
future version of yourself from New York
man it really might be it's it is but I
will say this that rejection is the
greatest thing that's ever happened to
me in my career
mmm it has given me my career everything
great from my career has come from
rejection I thought about that
everything uh I made this comedy special
for for one which is originally an
hour-long special and I'm sure you guys
have heard this story before that I've
told the podcast but
and I tried to sell it to all the
networks all of them said no and it was
the lowest time in my career I was like
I might not - in comedy where any like
what's going on why is the industry
never opened their arms to me never
opened the doors like what the [ __ ] is
happening I'm good at this [ __ ] and I
said you know what [ __ ] it this is good
I'm gonna put out a smaller version and
the reason I decided to put a smaller
version now is because I would ask
friends that we're not comedians about
comedy you can learn so much about your
own industry from asking people who know
nothing about it and I'd ass on my bag
hey you watching a comedy they'd be like
and I'm like who do you like no I like
this guy John Mulaney it could be
anybody right and then be like oh yeah
would you you know what you like about
this and I was just good you know and
then they'd all say this they go I
didn't finish it but I mean it was good
they've all said I didn't finish it I
started like mental spreadsheet in that
and I was like didn't finish it didn't
finish it okay so nobody's watching the
whole thing this is good to know so I go
I'm gonna put out a 15-minute special
there has for the comedy clubs instead
of the five that I did and has the cab
rides in between etcetera so it's gonna
be a 15 minute comedy experience I call
it but special I'm gonna put it out and
because nobody's watching the whole
thing and I want to leave them you know
the best meal is the one that you could
have had one more bite of right so I put
it out and like that weekend I sell out
some shows in San Diego and I was like
this is so in what's so weird is this
past weekend I was just in San Diego at
the same club and I sold out the whole
weekend so it's interesting to see
what's what's going on I saw this one I
was like I was never sell out guys like
what the [ __ ] is happening here and um I
was in some R and I was in Ohio or
Columbus like the place I don't have any
draw and I sold like 1600 tickets in a
weekend I was like what the [ __ ] is
happening and I go okay I'm doubling
down on this content [ __ ]
and I started put a new joke out every
single week every Sunday and I was I
gonna do this for a year a new joke for
a year and the jokes start to go viral
and my family started to blossom when I
started to like sell out these shows and
I realize oh [ __ ] the game has changed
and nobody knows it yet but I just
figured out that it changed so I'm
sitting here it's like finding
[ __ ] the metal in Wakanda you know to
me by brainy guy vibranium or some [ __ ]
like that like and I'm just like I'm
holding it I'm like oh my god nobody
knows and everything starts to make
sense to me I start to go would anybody
listen to anything that's an hour if you
didn't know them like would you listen
to anyone talk for an hour if you didn't
know I'm like if somebody said hey man
check out this guy Dave Johnson it's an
hour long watch it you like are you
[ __ ] crazy no it would it would take
some some sort of otherworldly yes a
miracle to make that happen right and
even then I would only do it
begrudgingly grudgingly upset the whole
[ __ ] time so I was like oh so
specials are done please why would I
watch a special for an hour
why don't I even risk it it makes no
sense so I started putting out these
clips and then what I noticed is people
would watch a clip and then they'd watch
for two hours so people aren't watching
your comedy special but they get lost in
my youtube wormhole for double the time
because it's a digestible byte and it
comes one bite even though you're taking
a special one bite at a time
you don't know when you feel the
pressure to watch an hour it's like
someone's jamming the pizza into your
face this is just hey here's a little
big ol pizza bagel and I kept on
throwing them out there and [ __ ] explode
and I started selling tickets and I
would put this stuff on social I put on
Instagram and I've really I really
changed comedy in a way because the
specials our specials are done nobody
realizes it just yet but specials are
done and now comics have adopted my
blueprint and I do it for them this is
not like oh you're copying me like
anything I do is for creators why it's
all your a few well two years after your
special you Ray Romano is is doing
effectively the same thing and it's
maybe a compliment though right so yeah
and maybe it's parallel thinking I know
I know that that uh you know obviously
comedians will go from you know the the
seller to wherever village underground
wherever and do that but you were the
first
first and say I'm gonna take that night
and actually turn it into a creation of
mine I'm gonna produce this into a
creation that we can share on a screen
or digitally dude what I've realized
about just creating in general and I'm
sure you guys have had this you know
same experience after doing your podcast
and putting out your content having
success with it is like you you the
industry operates with the wind so
whatever direction the wind is flowing
they cast the sail and they go in that
direction okay they don't dictate where
the industry goes they follow it right
there a sailboat okay so if you want to
be the motorboat you have to get
underneath the water the motor from the
motor boat is underneath the water it's
not above it and that's how it fights
any current that's how it fights the
wind that's about everything so for me
my whole [ __ ] was okay I got to plant
the seeds and then these have to grow
into the industry so did Ray Romano see
my special girl I want to do that no I
assume not I always assume the best but
did I make it okay for an a-list
celebrity to do a special in a hundred
fifty seat comedy club yes because if
they pitched a network that before the
Vic why would you do that in this little
tiny club like I made that allowable
right I made that okay because it got
millions of views with like okay this is
fine I push the wind in that direction
right I got the wind flowing so
everything that I'm trying to do now is
about getting underneath and letting it
grow in are you guys familiar with how
Nescafe got into the Japanese market no
no I know we got to be quick with these
but I'll be quick the story so Nescafe
he talks his consultant he's like a
super you know the most successful
consulting in the world with this kind
of [ __ ] like that and like how do we get
into Japanese market and the guy goes I
looked at the culture I looked at the
people you're not gonna be able to get
in there for 15 years and he's like what
are you talking about he goes they have
no concept of coffee you're trying to be
tea or not tea they have no
understanding Google coffee as they have
no memories attached to coffee it means
nothing to them
right what you're gonna have to do is
you're gonna have to spend millions of
dollars making a cartoon make that
cartoon popular then you're gonna make a
candy based on that cartoon that candy
it's gonna be flavored like coffee 15
years from now when these kids are grown
up they're gonna love that [ __ ]
coffee Wow go to Japan right now and
show me and just take a look at what
they're drinking devouring coffee yeah
like never before it has absolutely it's
like this uh the single origin pour over
cold brewed nitro like that is you know
that kind of swept the nation a few
years ago but like yeah over in Japan
it's yeah it's nuts it absolutely is and
that is all everything that I'm doing
right now that inside joke so it's fun
for me because I just love talking to
comments about jokes but the the seed
that I'm growing is hey guys this is how
we come up with these bits there's no
reason to be offended it's a puzzle for
us it's a game right once you watch the
game and watch how we put it together
then when you see an offensive joke
onstage you're not convict how could he
say that you're gonna be like oh he's
working on it I see this idea I've seen
those other guys in the restaurant do it
that's probably gonna be funny in a few
weeks right and you're not setting out
to offend people
you're also not setting out to not
offend people either that offend you
this offense yeah yeah and and I can't
decide you should be offended by this or
you shouldn't you get offended or
whatever you want
maybe it's appropriate maybe it's not
but that doesn't need to go into the the
it's cancerous for the creative process
when we think we're constantly but like
you said and now we have more access
than ever with social media to like to
constantly get little cancer cells
responding back to us all the time you
can't you can't criticize someone you
can't criticize art based on a malleable
term right so it's like shock that's
just shock value it's like yeah like
look at any painting from the
Renaissance yeah it's shocking yeah
that's what we do now here's the thing
about being shocked you know it's
shocking to a Muslim dude if you say
Jesus Christ as our Lord and Savior
that's shocking right you know it's
shocking to a Jewish guy if you say
Jesus Christ I learned sit like this is
shocking
wildly shocking right yeah so it's like
to say you can't be shocking is a stupid
argument because you cannot define what
you'll be shocked about to say to a
vegan
you're like a nom --let might be
shocking hmm it's a stupid litmus test
for what you can and can't say they're
only stupid people use it's basically
people trying to frame they're trying to
put like a framework on what they do
because they know that they're in a safe
they're like hey this is the safe space
I operate in and anything outside of
space shouldn't be done mmm so you're
trying to be like you're trying to be
like the NBA or the NFL deck there's
only 29 teams sorry guys right you got a
plate you got a play in here what you've
realized is you no longer need the
permission slip and Ryan and I realized
this early on actually let's talk talk
about that more on the maximum episode
let me get to two tweetable answers in
here real quick the first one is Austin
if you're true to yourself
you needn't wallow in rejection and I
think I think you're a great example
this man it's like you stay true to
yourself you didn't be like oh I didn't
sell a special how do I need to alter
this next time so I can spell sell that
special next time and then also you kind
of touched on a little bit Andrew the
power to use I'm sorry the power to
discern between criticism and feedback
will help you get the most out of
rejection so you've got you have got you
have got to look at what people are
telling you and ask yourself like are
these just like are these just critics
or is this valuable feedback so I I just
realized that right now hmm I needed it
because I wasn't built to lead yet like
I wasn't prepared to line eaded to have
everything stripped I need to be zero
before I was complete prepared to lead
because once I was okay with zero now I
can give yeah man
see what I'm saying plus the blank slate
is is like a beautiful place from which
to create you're not trying to say well
now I'm gonna do five five one part to
know that that's a chapter and and and
you've moved past that for the sake of
time I'm gonna skip past our added value
segment Ryan I'm gonna skip past right
here right now other than to say we have
a bunch of upcoming
cast episodes with Rachel Cruise Ben
Greenfield TK Coleman Colin Wright and
Cal Newport the author of digital
minimalism he's coming in we've done a
couple events with him in the past so
you'll be able to check those out coming
soon for this minimal episode I want to
say thanks to Andrew for being here and
check him out at youtube.com yeah check
it out views from the syph used from the
SIS drops every Sunday March the intro I
dropped surprisal Beyonce dropped the
week before but every Sunday in March a
new a new part of it so I chopped up the
special takes place in four different
countries there's also a tour
documentary I did with it that comes out
on our dropping in series but so where's
the best place to go to see that uh
youtube.com search the end results okay
every Sunday new clip two o'clock and
we're pushing it man where we are
pushing it and I think it this first one
that I'm dropping this Sunday March 3rd
is I think it's the best Trump joke ever
written about rate of freedom we're
gonna talk about moving corporate
boundaries we're gonna talk about
burnout I don't know if that's something
you've gone through injury we'd love to
talk to you about those also we have
some questions about those also I want
to talk to you about content versus
meaningful creations and and how we
delineate the two and I want to talk
about how you've turned some of your
rejection into success and if you all
want to hear all of that you can listen
to this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the the
private space we need to be well a
little more flagrant right yeah yeah
yeah believe it or not it's gonna get
more flagrant when you subscribe to the
minimalist podcast on patreon the
private podcast you'll also receive a
personal links of our maximal episodes
play in your favorite podcast app and
you got to get your patreon subscribers
onto that man what is
yeah yeah so on patreon what what you do
is we want you signed you get a private
link as a patron okay right
and then whatever podcast player you use
Apple podcasts overcast feedly whatever
it is whatever you're using on your
phone you just paste that link in there
and then automatically downloads all the
new episodes you don't have to go to the
patreon page or patreon app you listen
to it write down your phone you get all
the new episodes right there yeah so if
if you're if you're a patron of ours you
also have access to a hundred past
episodes private episodes you can find
all the details and all the good stuff
over at the minimalists com
slash supports Ryan what else you got
for us as always I just want to
encourage people read more and get
informed and now here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
hi this is Emily Lewis from Baltimore
Maryland and I have a comment for the
episode reset specifically the question
on how to get a long time as a busy
introvert I am also an infj
and crave time alone yes have always
been incredibly busy throughout my life
and had trouble saying no I didn't
understand why until I read the book
radical acceptance by Tara brach in
which she says staying occupied is a
socially sanctioned way of remaining
distant from our pain how often do we
hear that someone who has just lost a
dear one is quote doing a good job at
keeping busy end quote
if we stop we run the risk of plunging
into the unbearable feeling that we are
alone and utterly worthless this passage
made me realize that while I wanted time
to be alone I was also afraid of it I
highly recommend this book to everyone
hi my name is Cody and I'm Frederick
Maryland I've always seen the
professional photographers you shoot for
the big news companies and blogs and all
the corporations and their equipment is
out of this world and they can take any
picture they want to in three different
bodies and all these expensive lenses
and I have my $400 camera and I have to
get right to the side lines that get a
halfway decent picture but after
listening to your podcast to kind of
help me realize how I can focus on other
aspects that can focus on making sure I
organize the picture and do keywords so
that it's searchable in the archives and
making sure that means good
communication skills to take pictures of
who I need to and kind of work but
everything else except for the picture
itself and how I but it doesn't really
hold me back but actually helped me
improve all right Joe that's it for this
episode you can comment on this episode
youtube.com slash the minimalist if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list the minimalists
comm is the address you just typed in
your email address at the top you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
each week and if you leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus